my question is marry shag kill dylan
sprouse Cole Sprouse Zac Efron and you
can't plead the fifth okay Ashley
Tisdale in the hot seat on Wednesday
night's episode of watch what happens
live marry shag kill so you marry one
Chegwin kill when cole sprouse dylan
sprouse zach i think we picked twins and
Zach this is so brutal man I would say I
wish Cole Sprouse okay who do you kill
you marry dylan sprouse
oh good guy kill Zac Efron I'm bummed
out I mean I guess I kind of get it
those were hard choices of course Ashley
worked with all three guys on Disney
projects back in the day with the
Sprouse twins on the suite life of zack
& cody no Maddie where do you trying out
for hello sure pay people say I look
just like her
Mountains and with Zach on all three
High School Musical movies you know Troy
I've always known you're special and
it's pretty obvious I'm special too
and to be fair it also makes sense that
she chose to kill Zach because he did
date Vanessa Hudgens during that time
[Music]
and a reminder Vanessa and Ashley are
still BFFs one two three they gonna run
back to me they they never wanna leave
but that's not all Ashley had to say
about her high school musical days she
also revealed there was one co-star who
she surprisingly did not get along with
right away Lucas Grable who played her
brother in the movies Lucas and I didn't
get along at first because when we were
screen testing I was giving him line
readings it's not an actor over yeah but
I I think it was more like I I don't
really do method acting but I took a
class in it when I was younger and I do
think I become a lot like the character
and I think he thought I was really like
Sharpay and it wasn't until we wrapped
that he was like oh you're not that
person and I was like yeah amazing
et actually chatted with Ashley about
High School Musical when it turned ten
here's what she had to say you know it's
a very special moment in our life and
going through that was it wasn't typical
because you know nobody thought it was
gonna be as successful as it was and it
was really purely because of the fans
that it was that successful and the fact
that they've supported us throughout all
these years it's been amazing all right
guys that is it for today what do you
think of Ashley's shag marry kill
choices let me know and for all the
latest on Ashley Vanessa the Sprouse
twins and Zach keep it locked to all
things
ét until next time I'm Katie Krause and
bye for now
[Music]